Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Akta ist mein Name und ich bin hier erst.
So erst möchte ich ein paar Fragen
Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir gleich
zu Ihren Beschwerden.
Ist das enorm?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Also der Patient kommt
in Begleitung der Frau
der Ehefrau
und der Patient kann
nicht selber richtig antworten.
Die Ehefrau antwortet.
Ja, die Ehefrau antwortet.
Die Ehefrau sagt
mein Mann heißt
Peter Spengemann.
Das ist der Name des Patienten.
Können Sie bitte
sein
Ihren
Ihren Mann
Vornamen
langsam bestärbieren?
Ja, Peter schreibt sich
Peter
ist der Vorname
und Spengemann
schreibt sich
Spengemann
Ja
Frau
Spengemann
Wie groß
Ihren
Mann sind?
Wie groß ist Ihr Mann?
1,84 m
Ja
Wie viel wiegen
er?
90 kg
Nein
Wie viel wiegen
er?
90 kg
Was ist der Hausarzt?
Der Hausarzt ist Dr.
Meier
Was
für Sie uns welche
Habbeschwerde haben?
Ja, also jetzt
Frau
Mein Mann
ist in den letzten 12 Stunden
sehr verändert
er hat sich sehr verändert
er ist teilweise
sehr unruhig
und teilweise
aber auch sehr schläfrig
Teilweise schläft er
ganz viel und dann ist er
plötzlich auch wieder unruhig
etwas aggressiv
Er
kann schlecht gehen
er ist sehr unsicher
in gehen
und er muss sich oft festhalten
wenn er geht und heute Nacht
ist er auf dem Weg zur Toilette
ist er gestürzt
Also er ist sehr
unruhig, er ist teilweise
schläfrig
und er kann nicht so sicher gehen
und ist in der Nacht
einmal gefallen
gestürzt
seit wann
hat er
unruhig, schläfrig
oder
seit 12 Stunden
und früher
da ist mir das nicht so aufgefallen
okay, genau
sind diese Beschwerden
plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
ja, die sind langsam aufgetreten
aber so innerhalb
vielleicht von 1, 2 Stunden
sind sie aufgetreten
ja
er ist auch übel
er hat 2 Mal erbrochen
ja
es hat sich irgendwie
alles verändert in den letzten 12 Stunden
ja
ja, er fährt sonst
auch mit dem Fahrrad
jeden Tag fährt er sonst
mit dem Fahrrad
aber in den letzten
heute nicht
und seit gestern auch nicht
er ist zu unsicher
er sagt, ich kann nicht Rad fahren
ich fühle mich
unsicher, es geht nicht
heute
kann
er ihre Arme
und
beinahe ganz normal bewegen
oder
ist er
sind ohm-machtig?
nein, er kann das ganz gut bewegen
aber insgesamt
wenn er geht
können sie sich untersuchen
er geht sehr vorsichtig
und kleine Schritte
normalerweise ist er
sehr vital und aktiv
aber
wie gesagt, das ist seit 12 Stunden
hat sich das verändert
okay
ist er
schwindelig
oder ist es bewusst sein Verloge?
das bewusst sein
hat er glaube ich nicht verloren
aber
ihm ist jetzt auch glaube ich etwas schwindelig
und wie gesagt eben
also übel, er hat erbrochen
und ja
hat er
Schwierigkeiten beim
sehen oder sprechen?
nein, glaube ich nicht
beim sehen
glaube ich nicht
nein, beim sprechen eigentlich auch nicht
aber insgesamt ist er ruhiger
und wie gesagt, er schläft
jetzt viel und
er hat jetzt auch nicht so viel gesprochen
okay
ist ihnen
noch etwas auch gefallen
oder
das
Gleichgewicht
zu halten?
ja, das kann er nicht gut
er fühlt sich ja unsicher, er kann nicht gut gehen
und er möchte auch nicht Rad fahren
sonst fährt er immer mit dem Fahrrad
aber das will er nicht mehr
er sagt, ich fühle mich zu unsicher
unsicher, gerne
hat er Fiber?
ich glaube nicht
nein, Fiber hat er nicht
wie ist
er appetiert in letzter Zeit?
also, appetiert war immer gut
ja
hat er
abgenommen
oder zugenommen?
das glaube ich, er hat sein Gewicht gehalten
genau
hat er Probleme
mit dem Stuhlgang
oder was er lassen?
nein, Stuhlgang
ist regelmäßig
da geht er regelmäßig
und auf Toilette geht er glaube ich so 2 mal in der Nacht
das aber schon seit einiger Zeit
aber das stört ihn nicht groß
er kann danach normalerweise wieder gut einschlafen
zum Beispiel
Urin
oder Stuhlverlohren
nein, das hat er nicht
ok
schlaft er gut?
normalerweise schläft er gut
wie gesagt, jetzt seit 12 Stunden
schläft er auch ganz plötzlich
am Tisch ein
weil er so schläfrig ist seit 12 Stunden
normalerweise schläft er regelmäßig
und gut
hat er Müdigkeit?
ja, er ist ja sehr müde
und schläfrig
und dann wieder ist er plötzlich ganz aufgeregt
und auch manchmal
jetzt aggressiv
also er hat sich sehr verändert
hat er
ein Siedler?
nein
hat er Husten oder Luftnot?
Atomnot?
nein
hat er Herzrasen
oder Brustenge?
also er hat Herzrhythmusstörungen
und da hat er auch eine
Katheterbehandlung mal gehabt
vor 3 Jahren
um das Herz wieder
in den richtigen Rhythmus zu bekommen
aber das war nicht richtig
erfolgreich
er muss deswegen auch ein Mittel
für die Blutgerinnung nehmen
jeden Tag muss er eine Tablette
nehmen dafür
aber
er hat sich bisher immer
ganz wohl gefühlt
das war bisher ganz gut
immer
war immer in Ordnung
ja
sind diese Beschwerden
früher schon einmal
aufgetreten?
nein
so was hat er noch nie gehabt
ich kenne ihn jetzt ja schon über 30 Jahre
sind wir verheiratet 35 Jahre
so was hat er noch nie gehabt
ja
sind diese Beschwerden
mit der Zeit verändert?
nein
vor 12 Stunden
hat das angefangen
und
das hat sich jetzt so durchgezogen
also wie gesagt das mit dem Erbrechen
und der Übelkeit das ist jetzt in den letzten
2 Stunden gekommen
insofern hat es sich etwas verändert
etwas verschlimmert
verschlimmert
haben Sie beim Erbrechen
etwas Auslöse für die Schmerzen
für diese Beschwerden
Auslöser
ich weiß es nicht
also ich kann mich erinnern
mein Sohn hat mich dran erinnert
vor ca. 3 Wochen ist er einmal
mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt
und
er hatte da
eine kleine Platzwunde am Kopf
aber die war klein
wir haben einen Pflaster drauf gemacht
und
er sagt es geht ihm gut
ich habe ihn gefragt
ob er bewusstlos war
konnte er sich nicht genau erinnern
es gibt auch keinen Zeugen
für den Sturz
er ist danach aber wieder weiterrad gefahren
das war so ungefähr
vor 3 Wochen
ok
um
waren Sie in letzter Zeit krank
und beim Arzt
bei diese Beschwerden?
nein
die sind ja jetzt erst seit 12 Stunden aufgetreten
diese Beschwerden
und da waren wir bisher noch nicht beim Arzt
aber heute Morgen haben wir gesagt
es wird schlimmer
es geht ihm nicht gut
wir müssen in die Notambulanz
ok
in Ordnung
Frau
Frau Spingermann
ich hatte ein paar Fragen
so
ihre Mann
haben wir eine Krankengeschichte
ja
leiden Sie an einer bestimmten chronischen
Erkrankung
mein Mann
muss immer Tabletten nehmen gegen hohen Blutdruck
das ist
ungefähr seit 10 Jahren
und wir messen regelmäßig
den Blutdruck fast jeden Tag einmal
zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten
und der Blutdruck war in letzter Zeit immer gut
er nimmt die Werte
dann auch mit zu seinem Hausarzt
und der ist zufrieden
und wie gesagt
er hat diese Herzrhythmusstörungen
da hat er diese Katheterbehandlung gehabt
vor 3 oder 4 Jahren
war das
aber ansonsten
hat er keine chronischen Erkrankungen
gibt es
weitere Erkrankungen?
nein
sind Sie
ist er
schon einmal operiert geworden?
ja als Kind
da weiß ich aber nicht genau wie alt er war
so 10 Jahre alt
am Blindarm operiert worden
und dann ist er
noch an den Mandeln operiert
worden
auch in der Kindheit
das waren die Operationen
okay
genau
nehmt
er
regelmäßig
gelegentlich mit Kament
er nimmt
Tabletten ein
ich habe das hier auf dem Zettel
da steht drauf
Rami Priel
das ist glaube ich Blutdruck
ein Blutdruckmittel
morgens eine und abends eine Tablette
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Ich stärke
dahinter steht 5
weitere Medikamente
dann
nehmt er noch ein anderes
Blutdruckmittel bisoprolol
da steht auch 5
hinter
und dann nehmt er
auch morgens eine Tablette
und abends eine Tablette
genau
und dann nehmt er noch ein Medikament
das ist wegen der Blutgerinnung
weil er ja
diese Herzrhythmostörung hat
der Arzt gesagt das muss er ganz wichtig
muss er das jeden Tag nehmen
das heißt Lixiana
Lixiana
da nehmt er eine Tablette von
äh
dahinter
eine Tablette
60 steht dahinter
und
für Herzrhythmostörung
nehmt er
eine Medikamente
der Arzt hat gesagt
dieses
Mittel bisoprolol
das sei auch etwas gegen Herzrhythmostörung
aber auch
für seinen Blutdruck
also zusammen ein Kombinationsmittel sei das
genau nur bisoprolol
ja
hat er
allergien oder
Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, soweit mir bekannt ist
nein, der verträgt alles
der kann alles essen
und hat keine allergien
Nein
Raucht er?
Nein, der raucht nicht
äh, trinkt er
irgendwie
ja, Alkohol trinkt er aber selten
selten mal eine Flasche Bier
das ist aber nicht jeden Tag
vielleicht pro Woche eine Flasche
bis zwei Flaschen pro Woche
äh, mutimäßig
muss ich fragen, haben Sie
hat er Kontakt
mit irgendwelchen Drogen gehabt?
Nein, soweit ich weiß nicht
Nein, das macht er nicht
genau
äh
Was ist er vom Beruf?
Also mein Mann
ist Hausmeister in einer Schule
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, drei Kinder
ähm
Person ist 34 Jahre alt
und zwei Töchter
die sind 29 und
27 Jahre alt
die sind gesund
äh, wohnen Sie
zusammen? Ja
Also ich wohne mit meinem Mann
zusammen, die Kinder wohnen nicht mehr bei uns
die sind in anderen
Leben in anderen Städten
äh, leiden
Familienangehörige
an wichtige Erkrankungen
zum Beispiel, Sucherkrankheit
Auto, Krebs und so weiter
ähm
ähm, der Vater
meines Mannes
äh, der ist 86 Jahre alt
der lebt, der hat hohe
auch hohe Blutdruck
und er hat eine schwere Hüftartrose
auf der linken Seite
aber er will sich nicht operieren
lassen, ähm, er geht
an einem Rollator
ja, die Mutter
die ist 84 Jahre alt, die lebt
auch noch, sie hatte vor
20 Jahren Brustkrebs
das ist aber
insgesamt gut verlaufen, die Behandlung
und die Zeit danach
und sie hatte vor
10 Jahren einen
Bandscheibenvorfall
ähm
und wurde äh, operiert
vor 10 Jahren
äh, Entschuldigung, äh
wie alt
ihre Mutter
ist 84 Jahre alt
ja, ähm
genau
äh, hat ihr
hat ihr Mann Geschwister
äh, mein Mann
hat keine Geschwister, nein
genau
äh, wann
ist er das letzte Mal
im Urlaub
das letzte Mal im Urlaub
waren wir im Herbst, im Oktober
da waren wir
ja, 10 Tage
in Österreich
äh, wie ist
ihr Impfstatus
mein Mann der Impfstatus
äh, ich glaube, da lässt er immer regelmäßig
äh, das kontrollieren, er hat
auch im Herbst, das haben wir zusammen gemacht
äh, eine Impfung gegen
Corona
haben wir gemacht und eine Impfung gegen
Grippe
das machen, haben wir immer gemacht
gegen das im Herbst, im November
und ich glaube, sonst ist er
äh, ausreichend geimpft
also der Hausarzt hat
immer gesagt, das ist in Ordnung, das passt
wie viel Mal
gegen Corona gehen
ich glaube, jetzt das fünfte Mal
fünfte
äh, wann war ihre
Impfung, da das letzte Mal
äh, aufgefügt
das kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen
ich habe jetzt den Impfpass von meinem Mann
nicht mit, das muss ich dann zu Hause
nochmal den Impfpass holen
und Ihnen dann zeigen
aber wie gesagt, der Hausarzt hat immer
gesagt, zur Zeit, es ist alles im Augenblick
in Ordnung
aber ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau
weil ich den Impfpass, das habe ich nicht im Kopf
äh,
wir sind jetzt fertig, haben Sie
noch Informationen da
wichtig sein könnten?
Was kann der mein Mann denn haben?
ich mache mir große Sorgen, weil er so
wie gesagt, er ist ganz anders
und so verändert und
ja
genau, ich verstehe Frau Spingenmann
äh, dass Sie
sich Sorgen machen
wir werden alle notwendigen
Untersuchungen
Schritt für Schritt durchführen, zum Beispiel
äh
so erst eine köpfelliche
Untersuchung durchführen
und Bluetooth Lopfer
Untersuchungen abnehmen
dann könnten weitere Untersuchungen
wie LKG, Röntgen,
Ultraschall,
CT, oder MRT
Schadenotik sein
sobald
wie sobald
wir alle Ergebnisse haben
erkläre ich Ihnen alles
genau und besprechen
das weitere vorgehend mit Ihnen
aber ich denke
Ihre Mathe hat
äh
kann
eine Hämologie
äh, im
äh
Gehirn
sind
ist
deswegen
wir sind eine
sofortige
Maßnahmen empfangen
okay, gut, das können wir so machen
prima, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit
äh
wir haben uns geeinigt so auf 10 Minuten
wenn Sie eher fertig sind, geht das eher
überlegen Sie sich die
Übersetzung der
Patientensprache in Fach
äh, medizinische Fachsprache
und wenn Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es sind ja jetzt doch noch viele
gekommen äh, Fragen haben
dann bitte ich Sie
diese Fragen zu stellen
ja
hat er Kopfschmerzen?
habe mir geflaggt
äh, wenn Sie das so sagen
hat er so in den letzten Tagen mal
über Kopfschmerzen geklagt
das kenne ich bei ihm gar nicht so
äh, normalerweise hat er nie
Kopfschmerzen, aber in den letzten Tagen
hat er mal so gesagt, ach ich hab so ein bisschen
Kopfschmerzen, und er hat gesagt, das ist
das Wetter, äh, es wird
jetzt so warm, es ist das Wetter
aber mehr haben wir jetzt nicht gemacht
hat er Taubheitsgefühl
oder äh, Grebel?
Nein, ist mir, nein
müsste man ihn vielleicht
nachher nochmal genau fragen
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, aber soweit ich
weiß, nein
ich habe aber den Eindruck, wenn ich ihn jetzt
auch nur weltweit frage, dass er nicht
immer, äh, so
ganz richtig antwortet, er ist
manchmal etwas verwirrt
ja, hat er, hat
ich sage mal
verwirrt
verwirrt? Ja, ist etwas
verwirrt sagt man, glaube ich
aber das erst seit gestern
seit ungefähr zwölf Stunden
ja, ich stamm mich
Sie haben gesagt
dass
er, äh, er
erbrichen haben
ja, er hat zweimal
erbrochen, ja
plötzlich, äh, fangt
er an oder langsam?
Ja, er hat so
gesagt, mir ist übel
äh, äh, überübel
und dann hat er aber auch relativ schnell
erbrochen, ich habe mir das
angeschaut, das Erbrochene
das war so gelblich, schleimig
er hatte vorher, glaube ich, etwas gegessen
einen Apfel gegessen und ein
Stück Brot, ja, das waren
so Speisereste
die er dann erbrochen hat
Ja, warum, Kollegen, noch
an die Frage?
Augenblick, ist kein
Fragebedarf mehr, aber der Kollege
glaube ich noch am, am
Schreiben
das ist jetzt ja so
einer wenigen Fälle, die
wir sozusagen als Fremd an am Nese
ja, ja, aber
mir
eine Falle gibt es
Fremd an am Nese und deswegen
eine Schöne, ja, das ist
eine schöne, danke schön, vielen Dank
gerade bei
älteren Patienten
wird das immer häufiger
oder häufig vorkommen, dass
Patienten disorientiert sind
verwirrt sind, das
muss dann eine Fremd an am Nese
zum erstes bitten werden, ne
Entschuldigen
wie ist
hier man
alt
ja
wie alt er ist, er ist 62
Jahre alt, 62
62 Jahre, ja
geboren am 24.
März
1963, er hatte
jetzt gerade Geburtstag
ja
hat er letzte Woche ausbüllen
genommen oder
andere Medikamente letzte Woche
nein, mein Mann nimmt sonst keine
Medikamente, der ist, der nimmt nur
die Blutobmittel und dieses Mittel
für die Blutgerinnung
aber
andere Mittel und Schmerzmittel und so
nimmt man nicht, da ist er ganz
nein, da ist
er ganz geizig, das will er nicht
und hier hat man regelmäßig
Hausarzt oder Kardiologische Kontrolle
gehabt? Ja, ja, ja
er muss wegen dem
Herzen, geht er so
einmal im Jahr zum Kardiologen
und
war da die letzte Kontrolle, war
der Kardiolog so weit zufrieden
aber er muss eben
regelmäßig diese Medikamente nehmen
okay
Aktaika, können wir
anfangen?
Ein bisschen Zeit brauche ich
okay
das ist ja auch in Ordnung
in der Prüfung
haben Sie etwas mehr Zeit
sich vorzubereiten?
20 Minuten
bei der nächsten Woche
ist denn da
noch Ramadan
nächste Woche? Nein,
Ramadan am Ende
Samstag
Sonntag
Sonntag, Sonntag, Samstag
am Ende
also Monatsende sozusagen
okay
Sonntag können wir
alles essen
okay, gut
wissen Sie schon, was Sie essen?
alles
alles, gut
so
ja
okay
können wir starten?
genau
bitte schön
ich bin jetzt ja Oberarzt
ja Oberarzt
ich würde Ihnen
gerne einen Patienten vorstellen
denn ich gerade eben
in der Notauchnämie gesehen habe
können Sie
kurz Zeit? Ja, habe ich
haben Sie
Herr Peter Spingermann
62 Jahre alt
1,84 cm
groß
und 19 kg schwer
der Patient
stellt sich bei uns
vor Aufgrund seit
12 Stunden
langsam
aufgetretenen
unruhig
und unruhig
schlaftig
aggressiv
sagen Sie vielleicht
der Patient kommt
in Begleitung der Ehefrau
genau
und die
Anamnese wird
über die Ehefrau erhoben
das sollten Sie
zu Anfang sagen
weil der Patient berichtet
ja nicht selber
der Patient kann wahrscheinlich nicht adäquat antworten
sondern die Ehefrau
wird befragt
zur
Vorgeschichte des Mannes
ja
der Patient
begleitend
ihre Frau
und ich
frage
meine Fragen
ihre
Ehefrau
ich habe
die Anamnese
mit Hilfe
der Ehefrau
erstellt
genau
Sie haben kurz berichtet
seit 12 Stunden
hat der Patient
eine Symptomatik
woraus besteht die Symptomatik
Was hat er für Symptome
die Symptome
in
unruhig
schlaftig
aggressiv
man kann sagen
agitiert
es teilweise
vielleicht
subnulent
ja
das kann man vielleicht sagen
und das Ganze seit 12 Stunden
Konklusion
und in den Tagen vorher
war der Patient da irgendwie auffällig
oder ist das jetzt sehr plötzlich
gekommen
diese Entwicklung
die Beschwerden
sind
langsam aufgetreten
und mit der Zeit
verschlimmet geworden
gibt es noch
andere Symptome bei dem Patienten
ja genau
andere Symptome
die der Patient hat
über
Übelkeit
und
2 Mal Emesis
Nausea
Nausea und 2 Malemesis
Können Sie das
Erbrochene, haben Sie das
erfragt, wie das Erbrochene
aussieht
Entschuldigung
ich
diese Frage nicht fragen
Ja gut, die Frau hat kurz berichtet
es war
wohl etwas Speisereste
Brot
und etwas Apfel, was er vorher gegessen hatte
kein Blut, keine Blutbecken
Essenwäßchen
Okay, gibt es sonstige Symptome
sonstige Symptome
ich
frage
eher
haben Sie
bemerkt
einige Aussprache
für die Beschwerden
und sie
sagte das
sie sagte das
mein
Ihren
Ihren Ehemann
ja
3 Wochen
Fahrrad
Fahrrad gestürzt
er hatte einen Sturz
mit dem Fahrrad
und
jeden Tag
Ihren Mann
Radfahren
Allerweils fährt er jeden Tag
mit dem Fahrrad, ja
und heute
gegen diese Beschwerden
nicht Radfahren
ja, er ist unsicher
unsicher
hat der Patient sonst noch Auffälligkeiten
kann er gut gehen
ist er sicher
in Gehen
ist er gestürzt
in letzter Zeit
ja
vor 12
Stunden
in der Nacht
ist er auf dem Weg
zur Toilette gestürzt
gestürzt
und
der Patient
nimmt
regelmäßig
Blutgerinnung
ein
er
Name Lixiana
60 Milligramm
ja, Lixiana
60 Milligramm, warum
nimmt er Lixiana ein
äh
er
er nimmt
Lixiana gegen
Adrenalfibrillation ein
ja, oder gegen
Herzrhythmusstörungen
eher Frau berichtet
dass der Mann
Lixiana einnehmen muss wegen seiner Herzrhythmusstörungen
gibt es dazu
noch eine Vorgeschichte
können Sie dazu noch etwas sagen
äh
seit wann sind die Herzrhythmusstörungen
und sind die versucht worden anders
zu behandeln
äh
ich verges
und nicht
genotisiert
also der Patient hat seit 5 Jahren
Herzrhythmusstörungen
die Patientin kann nicht genau die Diagnose
sagen, wie das heißt
und es ist aber
vor 3 Jahren oder 4 Jahren sagt sie
ein Herzkatheter gemacht
und da hat man versucht
diese Herzrhythmusstörungen
zu behandeln
wahrscheinlich war es eine Katheter-Aplation
ja
wahrscheinlich eine Applation
die aber wohl nichts erfolgreich war
äh so sagt die Frau
also er hat weiterhin seine Herzrhythmusstörungen
und er nimmt
Lixiana 60 ein
okay
nimmt er sonst noch Tabletten ein
wegen anderer chronischer Erkrankungen
äh
er habe äh Artriol Hippatoni
seit 10 Jahren
äh
mit äh
Ramipril Morgen und Abend
äh
behandelt
ja, welche Stärke?
5 Milligramm
5 Milligramm, ja, und noch andere Tabletten
und Wiso Prool
5 Milligramm
morgens und abends
okay, gut
ja, ist der Patient schon mal
operiert worden?
ja, äh
der Patient als Kind
äh
bei dem Patient sei als Kind
äh Appendectomie
und äh
Konzillectomie
äh durchgeführt worden
genau, ja, gut
bringen wir ab
äh und ähm
Noxen
äh
Rauchen und
Drogenkonsum wurden verneint
äh
Trinke, gelegentlich
äh Bier
äh
Trinke, ein Flasche Bier
gelegentlich Provohe
okay, also ein
äh ein mäßiger Alkoholkonsum
ja, gut
ich wiederhole einmal kurz, was ich mir gesagt haben
also, der Herr Spengermann
der kommt in die Ambulanz
in Begleitung seiner Ehefrau
die Ehefrau berichtet, dass der Patient
seit 12 Stunden auffallend
verändert ist
äh er sei agitiert
er sei teilweise sogar etwas
aggressiv, dann wieder
äh Somnolent
und desorientiert
er kann äh nicht adäquat
antworten auf bestimmte Fragen
äh
unsicher im Gehen, sein Gangbild ist unsicher
er ist in der Nacht
auf dem Weg zur Toilette gestürzt
äh und
er hat äh
Nausea und zweimalige Emesis
äh das Erbrochen
äh ist unauffällig, sind Speisereste
kein Blut
und äh
der Patient ist sonst sehr aktiv
er fährt regelmäßig mit dem Fahrrad
äh das macht er jetzt seit
dieser Zeit nicht mehr
äh in der Vorgeschichte ist erwähnenswert
dass die Frau sagt vor 3 Wochen
sei der Patient mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt
ohne
weitere Zeugen, aber er berichtet das
und er habe sich
äh äh am Kopf
gestoßen, hatte eine kleine
Kopfplatzwunde, die aber
verheilt ist
und äh ja
er nimmt Tabletten ein
äh ging seine Artigale Hypertonie
Ramieprin 5, Bisoprol 5
jeweils 2 mal eine, er nimmt
Lixianer 60, ein
einmal eine, weil er wohl
wahrscheinlich ein
persistierendes Vorhofflemmern hat
äh es wurde eine äh
Katheter-Aplation versucht, die aber
wohl nicht erfolgreich war
gut, ähm
ja, gibt es Auffälligkeiten
in der Familienvorgeschichte
äh ja
ihre Mutter
haaa
seine Mutter
äh äh äh
84 Jahre
alt
noch lebt
vor 20 Jahren
äh Mama Karzinom
äh erlte
ja
äh und gut Behandlung
äh äh vor
10 Jahren
äh
vorfall
ja
versuchen Sie mal
das medizinische
kennt jemand von den Kollegen den Begriff
Bandscheidenvorfall medizinisch
Croisband Riptur
ja
meniskopati
ist mehr am Knie, meniscus
sagen Sie ruhig Discus
Discus Prolaps
ja, Discus Prolaps
wahrscheinlich wurde äh die Mutter
vor 10 Jahren wegen eines Discus Prolaps
operiert im Bereich der
Lendenwirbelsäule, gibt und der Vater
lebt der Vater noch?
und Vater äh äh
86 Jahre
Jahre alt
hat arteriales
Hypertony
ja
und äh
an äh
coxarthrosa leide
eine schwere coxarthrose ja
okay, gut
ja, das ist ja schon
in Ordnung, gut
ähm
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
äh
ich vergiss äh
Beruf und Sozialanamnese
ja, ja gut, das können Sie bitte noch ergänzen
ja, was ist der Patient vor Beruf?
äh der Patient
sei Hausmeister
in Schule
ich habe drei Kinder
äh und äh
mit äh ihr
mit ihr Frau äh wohnen
ja, der Patient wohnt
zusammen mit seiner Ehefrau
und die Kinder wohnen aber woanders
ja, gut
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
äh
Aufgrund der Symptomatik
habe ich den Verdacht auf
ein äh
cranial Hemmologie
ja, warum?
äh
da
da der Patient
äh
äh regelmäßig
nicht
nicht regelmäßig Lichsiana
einnehmen
okay
und vor
zwölf Uhr
im Toilette gestürzt
ja, das war vor aber er hatte ja die Symptomatik
dieser Veränderung
schon vor dem Sturz
in der Toilette
da war er ja schon verändert
da war er äh
sicher und äh
war aggressiv, war somnolent
äh
seit zwölf Stunden hat er ja eine Symptomatik
gut, also Hemmuragie
äh äh in die Richtung
ja, hat noch jemand
eine Idee von den Kollegen?
Apoplex
ja, okay
er hat eine abwahrscheinlich absolute
Arrythmie, er hat ein hohes Risiko
für ein äh Apoplex
kann er haben
aber denken Sie nochmal an den Fahrradsturz
vor drei Wochen
ähm
da wurde gerade hier gesagt
an alle subdual Hematom
ja, der Meinung bin ich auch
äh das
ist nicht selten
ein Mensch
ein vermeintliches Bagatell Trauma hatte
äh in diesem Falle
ein Sturz mit dem Fahrrad
er hat sich den Kopf angeschlagen
er muss gar nicht bewusstlos gewesen sein
er muss keine schwere Komozio gehabt haben
äh
dieser Patient ist vielleicht auch
äh etwas undifferenziert
und unkritisch gegenüber seinen Beschwerden
er hatte vor drei Wochen einen Fahrradsturz
ein in dem Sinne
vielleicht Schädel Hirntrauma
und das hat zu einer Sickerblutung geführt
äh weil er ja nun auch unter Lixianer steht
äh
und das kann nach Wochen
erst zu Symptomen führen
das muss nicht sofort sein
sondern das kann lange dauern
habe ich selbst schon erlebt bei Patienten
die auch mit dem Fahrrad
oder mit dem äh Motorrad gestürzt waren
oder Moped oder zu Hause die Treppe
gestürzt waren
also den Verdacht muss man haben
dass es ein subduales Hematom
ist bei den Patienten
Sie haben ja selber gesagt
Sie machen eine eingehende Diagnostik
Sie machen wahrscheinlich auch eine Bildgebung
des Schädels
äh und da wird dann selbst
bei einem CT wahrscheinlich das auch schon
herauskommt diese Verdachtsdiagnose
und differential diagnostisch
würde ich natürlich auch an einen
Apoplex denken
äh das kann natürlich sein
äh bei dieser
Risikokonstellation, Artegelle-Hypertonie
äh wahrscheinlich absolute Arytmie
äh und das ist natürlich
schon äh eine gewisse Risikokonstellation
Gut
ja erst mal
Ich hatte
ich hatte eine ähnlichen Patientin
als ich äh Gerberkt habe
in Türkeis
Ja, ja
weil es kann immer was sich, es passiert relativ häufig
Sie hat äh Diabetes
Melitotip 2
und äh
in Südengespritz äh eingenommen
und haa äh
Lyxiana 60 Milligramm
äh eingenommen täglich
Ja
äh äh sie hat im Toilette gestürzt
und langsam
aufgetretener diese Beschwerden
äh ja
ja, ja
Ich kann mich an einen Marathonläufer erinnern
äh
der war gut 60 Jahre alt
er war sehr ambitioniert, er hat schon mehrere Marathons gelaufen
er nahm keine Medikamente ein
keinerlei Medikamente
und war eigentlich
gut immer sportmedizinisch kontrolliert
aber der Patient entwickelte
eine Wesensveränderung
die Frau kam mit ihm in die Praxis und sagt
der ist völlig verändert
und der Patient im Nachherein
war er 2 Wochen vorher gestürzt
beim Marathon Training
im Wald
alleine gelaufen, keiner konnte
Fahrzeuge
ein gut duales Hematom
Professor an der hiesigen Universität
er konnte nachher aber
wieder äh äh in die Leere
und Vorlesungen halten, aber er musste
dringend notoperiert werden
Ja
so kann es passieren
Gut, erstmal vielen Dank
Gut, das ist ja
heute Abend sehr viele Menschen noch gewesen
Ja
Das fand ich gut und ich hoffe, dass sie es jetzt noch
zeitlich irgendwie schaffen
wir haben einen guten Abend
im Ramadan
und dass sie auch ihre Prüfung gut machen
und ähm ich würde sagen
wir sehen uns dann nächste Woche
dann wieder um 18 Uhr
18 Uhr
Gut, dann sage ich mal allen einen schönen Abend
und machen Sie es gut. Tschüss
Vielen Dank